your money is about to be rejected this  is because we're moving towards a social  credit score system this means you will  receive either a number or a score so if  you say the wrong thing like the wrong  thing on social media or don't do as  you're told like take the magic medicine  your score will go lower and people with  low scores won't be allowed to purchase  certain items this is all possible with  a central bank digital currency a  programmable cryptocurrency that is  entirely in the control of your  government so when your social credit  score falls too low your money will be  programmed to be used against you  central bank digital currencies allow  for an unprecedented amount of control  discrimination and coercion